hi i'm leslie mann and i'm judd apatow
and we're here to take the buzzfeed
relationship test
before we start we'd like you all to
know that we've been married for 24
years 25 in june so it'll be really
weird if we don't do well with this
birthday
march 8th what
we're not going to make it to 25.
december 6th march 26th
his favorite date night activity is
uh
like if he was in charge of the date
he'd be like let's listen to loud and
wainwright and the car ride to wherever
we're going exactly a really heavy
italian restaurant chicken parmesan and
then we would go
to see loud and wainwright in concert
and then listen to lamb wayne right out
of the car ride home
and your idea of a great date night you
like to watch dateline until you are
unconscious
guess the first time
that you realize that i had a crush on
you and vice versa he sent his sister
mia to see me and mia told me that
judd
was like in
demand with the ladies went on and on
and on like he judged so seriously i
mean so many girls so many girls and i
was like
why is she telling me this oh that was
just facts okay i get it
[Laughter]
we went to see a laker game on the way
there she didn't even know it was a date
and then on the way home
she suddenly went oh that was a date to
him
and then thought maybe mia was right
maybe now i get what the demand is about
favorite physical feature of yours my
smile oh right well not when you do that
you like my
eyes or my mouth
yes mouth
wow
because i read lips because
i never realized that you're supposed to
look people in the eye
because my parents i guess never looked
me in the eye they looked me in the
mouth and so leslie explained to me one
day when we first started dating
that i was she's like why are you
looking there and i'm like because i'm
listening to you their most used phrase
so what is my most used phrase no i
exactly and then
why didn't you feed the cats no i was
gonna
no i know why he's like the best phrase
no it's the worst your most used phrase
is rub my back
yeah that i guess though
yeah maybe shoe size i'm not allowed to
say her shoe sides because it's so big
she'd get embarrassed so next question
now what is it you're in like a men's
11.
it's not an 11 but what is my shoe size
this is he's go he wants to pass it
because he doesn't know it's a late
ladies nine
oh yeah
that's not that big but i squeeze into
the ladies nine yeah but you have so
much stability because when you have a
really long feet it's hard to knock you
over okay and you're a 10 and a half
you're you're 10 and a half i am a solid
10 and a half what do i think your
proudest moment is as a parent when we
saw that mod and irs decided to like
each other
yes
after hating each other for several
decades like a decade and then there was
a moment where we're like i think now
they love each other we nailed parenting
boom
sibling rivalry is over we're on the
same team now
what is
the favorite project of yours nikki
the drunk girl and the 40 year old
virgin
i mean that's one of them but no that's
probably not
okay this is where you could win the
whole thing okay your favorite project
was the gary documentary
well
did i just win that's pretty good
gary shanley
so that means you won i win
i should have said no
see i didn't lie damn it all right
that's the end of our test which leslie
won
and go see the bubble
on netflix it comes out april 1st so
when i say go see it i just mean turn it
on it's on your phone even
it's everywhere on your body
you just touch something and the bubble
will appear
in your life april 1st
[Music]
you